bush sera alors sur le web qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand on voit apparaître une
image puis on cherche à savoir si
l'image en question correspond à
l'histoire qu'on veut nous raconter
alors on peut vérifier ça en trois
étapes très simples
premièrement on sauvegarde l'image sur
notre appareil ensuite on utilise un
moteur de recherche d'image inversée et
puis on compare les résultats qu'on
obtient avec l'histoire initiale qui
accompagne et l'image qu'elle trois
étapes pour envoyer en détail pour la
première étape donc il imagé berti
comment comment faire alors premièrement
je te montre un exemple ici on a une
photo ici de gens qui sont en train de
prier et on nous dit que cette photo là
elle a été prise à montréal en 2016
alors on commence par sauvegarder
l'image sur l'autre appareil sur le une
tablette ou un téléphone on peut tout
simplement appuyé sur l'image et on a
l'option enregistrer l'image qui
apparaît si on est sur un ordinateur on
clique avec le bouton droit ont fait
enregistrer sous une image et
sauvegarder ce qu'on a trop de poissons
la deuxième étape c'est le moteur de
recherche qui entrent en ligne de compte
on pense souvent gogo donc sur liste
l'ordinateur on peut utiliser google
fonctionne très bien donc on peut
importer l'image dans le moteur de
recherche google et ça nous donne tous
les résultats
tous les sites internet où cette image
là apparaît sur un appareil mobile on
peut faire la même chose avec d'autres
moteurs de recherche
par exemple ici tenai alors on a une
flèche qui nous permet d'aller chercher
l'image qu'on a sauvegardé sur votre
appareil
on importe ici l'image dans le moteur de
recherche
et ça nous donne automatiquement encore
une fois toutes les copies de cette
image là sur internet je savais que
plusieurs résultats maintenant il faut
les trier il faut les prioriser pour les
analyser comment on fait alors si on se
rappelle l'histoire initiale qui
accompagné l'image on nous disait que la
photo de jean emprunt de prix c'était à
montréal en 2005
alors on veut comparer la date et le
lieu des résultats qu'on obtient donc
ici tout de suite on voit déjà que cette
photo là elle apparaissait sur internet
déjà en 2010 donc impossible que la
photo a été prise en 2016 et ensuite
est-ce que c'était à montréal on regarde
encore une fois les résultats qu'on le
petit
et on a plusieurs sites qui nous disent
que la photo aurait été prise à new york
donc en regardant les résultats comme ça
on peut finir par trouver que la photo
elle a été prise à new york en 2009
donc finalement une histoire qui
accompagnait la photo elle était fausse
mais voilà qui éclaire le verdict est
clair si on récapitule pour être sûr
d'avoir bien saisi les trois états donc
premièrement on sauvegarde l'image sur
notre appareil
deuxièmement on utilise un moteur de
recherche d'image pour aller trouver
d'autres versions de cette image là sur
internet
et troisièmement on compare les
résultats qu'on obtient avec l'histoire
initiale et on regarde si l'histoire
concorde avec les résultats et les
doutes sont dissipés merci bouge pas
après la pause ingérence étrangère quand
le gouvernement a mérité utilise
l'exemple de la pizza moyenne